[موسيقى]
انا لما باجي اتكلم في الموبايل بتاعي
يعني بص على حسب الموضوع اللي بتكلم فيه
ولما بتكون عندي شغل يعني على حسب بقى
الموضوع بيطول بيلفلف كده يعني مثلا ممكن
اه ممكن بقى زمان ده قبل الجواز الكلام ده
ساعه ساعتين براحتنا يعني مش اكثر من
دقيقتين ثلاثه لكن الرغي ده احنا بالرغم
ان انت طبيعتنا نحب الرغي دودو ابص الاقي
الست من دول ماسكه التليفون وقاعده الساعه
اتنين تلاته طبختي ايه عملتي ايه ساعات
اوقات مكالماتي ممكن غصب عني طول مني شويه
حسب فكره الموضوع لان المكالمات العائليه
مثلا ممكن يوم ما اقول ان انا خمس دقائق
مثلا مكالمات الشغل برضه نفس الرينج
تقريبا واحد صاحبك بيكلمك ممكن ياخذ معك
ثلاث ثواني بالضبط ايوه انت فين انا جيت
خلاص وكان واحده صاحبتك طبعا تختلف ازيك
الاول عامله ايه بتعملي ايه النهارده كده
بس
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات